I've done their work a shame in the
morning when they're kids like welcome
back to that would mean joshing today so
today we are joined by the class of
crazy rich Asians
awkwafina Gemma Chad how are you okay I
want to kind of get more crazy rich on
my own life so I'm gonna ask you for
some dating advice okay my pal needs a
makeover
and she hasn't had a date in a year it's
basically like sealed up it's that bad
what fire shall we go for now I think
she should get it suggestive but keep it
like classy sure but what do you think I
would go an extra and lay miserab so
that way is she's not too dressed up
right but she also seemed you know she's
and you don't have to take her out to
dinner too crazy of a garb you know you
just kind of don't know something utter
[Laughter]
deconstructed costume drama is the vibe
I'm guy yes yeah yeah
moles aplenty Dave's casual body he's
good to go yeah yeah sure okay
my mother-in-law has become a monster in
law how can I take the beep down town
how can I take her down the only viable
things are probably illegal you know
like a good old kidnap I like how we
went for illegal kind of yeah maybe like
she named her eyebrows in her sleep I've
been set up on a blind date
okay and it's going south mega quick how
does one escape what's the best escape
route the bathroom window
[Music]
it just calls your own afraid
imagine see emergency it cools your
phone you're like dad dad yeah yeah yeah
oh my god what see impressive yeah yeah
I think but they say by twice they go
not not like by by they go like bye-bye
do you have a good impression of me or
there's lots of rich material you could
do you like the wraps would be amazing
Oh Gemma and she loves wrapping our read
today we didn't little karaoke oh we did
your way and Gemma will be like no no no
no no and then take the mic and yes no
there was no twisting Gemma
but yeah she was up there Gemma
Sebastian what's your go-to rap just
called big lens bogus journey any time
travel dude where's my car
yeah Warner Brothers make our sequel a
hazard and Penguin I found out that my
lad is a Qi do I a go back be crazy and
destroy all of his worldly possessions
in the ceremonial bonfire like be keep
it classy keep it cute then forward all
of his suggestive texts he sent to his
lover to his family and friends have you
have you thought about this
C Lee partly but make sure take all the
diamonds
wow these are all very diabolical
revenge blots a I don't know what that
is but that's we can yeah yeah I feel
like if you got charm tank a gal pals
around a bonfire yeah I thought you
no ceremonial bonfire so we can just a
regular Saturday night basically your
character is a bit of a style icon in
the main King oh how do you suggest I
style out the walk of shame I think a
lot of it is what what has happened over
night to your face yes
you know if you maybe wearing fake out
of fake lashes that they then you know
kind of appear on your chin and you have
kind of a fake lash mustache you know
make sure maybe call me or pair a little
bit up huge sunglasses yes or that or
some scuba diving goggles natural yes
yes yeah you want that though I don't
know walk of shame in the morning when
they're kids they just like the Jeep's
the last on the water didn't you know
the to me but you the kids don't like
girls that was amazing I loved every
second of it